We're spending 48 hours in Austria,
then we're back for a day.
Then we're packing up the other kids
and spending September and the beginning of October
all over Europe and New York.
But first things first. We're getting ready to fly to Austria today.
It's a work trip for both lucky and I.
We're taking little whimsy Lou and the other kids are staying at home.
Lately, I've barely been getting any sleep.
I get four hours of sleep on a good night,
and I have the most vivid dreams,
which is absolutely crazy.
So naturally, I'm extra tired.
One of the first things I do is skincare,
and then the kids tend to wake up.
So we all make our way downstairs to start breakfast.
You guys know I need my hot cup of tea.
I've got so much tea
that I think I'll need a second tea drawer at this point.
My sister and my niece are here to watch the kids for us.
So I got started on making the kids some oatmeal.
I let that simmer, and then topped it with some strawberries,
some maple syrup, and some banana.
After that, I rushed upstairs and got myself ready,
cause I realized I barely had an hour
until our driver was here to pick us up.
So I put on some light makeup,
got dressed, and then got little whimsy Lou dressed as well.
Thirty minutes before our driver pulled up,
lucky realized that he was all Out of moisturizers.
So he made some really quick,
which took him about fifteen minutes
before we rushed down the stairs and got into the car
since we didn't wanna be late to the airport.
We made it there right on time.
I haven't been back to Europe in a while,
so I was very excited
going to a country that speaks the German language.
I realized we didn't have breakfast,
so we headed over to the lounge to grab some really quick
before boarding our flight.
This wasn't too long of a flight.
I think it was a nine hour flight to Paris
and then another few hours to Munich.
I always have to take my shoes off first thing,
scan the menu. But once we arrived, it was stunning.